[Applause]
on the streets to demand a pay rise in a
country that's struggling with one of
the highest inflation rates in the world
Venezuelan teachers and members of other
unions say the government needs to act
immediately to increase their wages
a teacher in Venezuela today earned 7 10
15 and 20 US dollars a month and those
who make between 20 and 25 dollars are
earning a partial salary why do I say
partial salary because it's only enough
to buy half a carton of eggs half a kilo
of meat we don't have a salary to
survive on
they marched to the prosecutor's office
in Caracas to make themselves heard
last year Venezuela's inflation rate was
more than 300 percent according to
unofficial estimates these people say
they haven't received a salary increase
since March 2022
today not only teachers but all public
servants are just scraping by President
Maduro this is not a lie this is reality
we're eating chicken feet and chicken
necks while you use scoundrel eat at the
best restaurants
foreign
[Music]
government has been trying to reduce
public spending and raise taxes to lift
Venezuela out of the hyperinflation
[Music]
that has forced more than 7 million
people to leave the country in recent
years
the government is struggling with U.S
sanctions in 2019 it relaxed private
sector regulations to allow more foreign
currency inflows while some Industries
have benefited Millions continue to
struggle president nadura blames the U.S
for the current economic situation
let's look for a common Destiny for
Venezuela a common goal and this must be
to say in one United voice enough with
the sanctions Joe Biden's government
lift all the criminal sanctions against
the Republic of Venezuela enough of
these criminal sanctions
[Applause]
people here say it's not just sanctions
that are hurting them but also the
government's mishandling of the economy
and that's why they say they will
continue to protest until their demands
are met
there is